[Music]
i didn't tell anyone for
about a year and when i did tell my mom
she didn't believe me you know she asked
me the typical questions like what were
you wearing so you have the initial
trauma and then you turn to the one
remaining adult in your life and say
help
and she says what were you wearing
[Music]
what's up
this is john with the dr john deloney
show
i'm so glad that you're with us i hope
you're well if your family's doing good
hope you're doing well
and in all the madness and all the chaos
and all the inflation and all the
frustration and anger and all this stuff
i hope you are finding
the light little glimpses
and some of you just like ah done with
this podcast too happy for me then it's
especially for you geez louise
um okay so this is pretty rad i'm old we
all know this
saturday night my buddy is like hey
we're going to see deftones you want to
come and i thought to myself
i haven't been mosh pitting in years so
i went
and i stayed up too late
and i ran around with a bunch of hot
topic kids and it was incredible they
put on they
they threw it down it was awesome
and on the way
uh my friends uh 18 year old son is in
college and 19 year old son put in a cd
or not a cd that's me because i'm 100.
uh scrawled on his iphone through um one
of the new found
uh these newfangled apps they called
them and uh when spotify and had a
introduced me to a new band
and it is really rare that i get into
new bands and this one
dude then turns out hey they're playing
here on tuesday and my friend pete's
like i got an extra ticket
and then it sold out like a 30 dude i
had two mosh pit shows
in like four days and let me tell you
this
my wife i came out i'm tired you can
hear my voice i may did a little bit of
mosh pit yelling
and some singing and by singing i mean
screaming my love is awesome and
my wife says you got a glow about you i
said i know i'm 22 again and she's like
how about we don't do that again because
that wasn't great for any of us but
go
find something that brings you joy
whether it's running around with a
thousand people
smashing into them or it's knitting or
gardening or picking up trash in your
neighborhood playing your guitar get
that thing out you've been under your
bed forever and you were gonna like play
some john mayer too whatever get it out
play it go make a move whatever you need
to do
go
find joy go find beauty it's a messy
messy time
it's up to you to go find it it's not
coming to you all right let's go to uh
elizabeth in cl oh by the way the band's
called turn style i figured i was like
it's the best ever you got to check them
out all right next caller that wasn't
very nice turn style listen
and you internet mean people i don't
know anything about this band i don't i
don't learn to listen to their words
i think they're lovely they may be mean
everybody relax all right let's go to
elizabeth in columbia south carolina
what's up elizabeth how are we doing
hi dr john it's so great to talk to you
it is super great to talk to you what's
up
all right so topic of my question is on
gun ownership
oh cool we're just gonna come out uh
we're gonna come out uh we're gonna slow
roll this one out of the gate way to go
all right let's talk guns back to the
point let's talk about it okay so
gun ownership and how to approach the
topic of bringing guns into the house
with my roommates okay need some
backstory back it up
okay so context so i i rent a house with
three other girls you know we're great
friends we've known each other for a
while part of the same church community
were great together and recently i found
out that one of them
actually is real has a history of having
guns is like a hobby like her family's
really into it and when i found out that
i was really excited because i've been
wanting to learn about how to shoot for
a while now okay and so when we both
found out that we were interested we got
really excited we talked about
potentially you know buying our own guns
in the future and going and she her
teaching me how to shoot and that's
going to the range and just having a
good time like that
the issue that we've come across is we
don't know how to approach
that topic with our other two roommates
like whether or not we need to even
disclose that we're getting guns at all
if we don't even plan on giving them any
access to them
or if we need to have like a roommate
meeting prior or i just wanted to get
your
opinion on that and think about if
there's any other factors i'm not taking
into consideration ah so i got so many
questions this is fantastic okay
um
trying to think of how to start
so let me frame it this way and this is
me talking to you this is me also
talking to the audience just to give
them some context
um i'm the son of a homicide detective
who was born and raised in texas
and
i had a great one of my therapy
professors my counseling professors she
dr marbley says
gave me some wisdom that was so great
she said she's from chicago and then
she's a professor in texas and she said
problem with talking about guns is we
talk past each other
because in texas
and i'm using texas in south carolina
and wherever right alabama whatever you
want to say um
regionally
grandmother will have a small gun in her
purse
it's just kind of like i don't i i don't
know anybody in my life i do now but at
the time i didn't know anybody in my
life that didn't have a shotgun i just
it's just a way of being and then in
she said in chicago i didn't know
anybody that had guns that wasn't some
involved in some sort of crime right and
and of course this is 15 years ago the
10 years ago says change but
she said so when somebody in one part of
the country hears about guns they
instantly have a picture of a bad person
in the other part of the country when
somebody mentions guns they instead have
a picture of their grandma
and so we end up with different pictures
we use the same words we're talking
about guns and gun ownership and what we
do and we talk past each other
and so i've been around guns my whole
life i have a bunch right not a bunch
like i'm not an arsenal guy but i
i i i that's that's and and
i've cleaned brains off of a bathroom
wall before
and i have
hugged mothers and i have been after
shootings and i've been uh
i've helped be a part of swat training
exercises so there is a stark reality to
the other side of this thing okay and i
think both sides of the conversation get
awesome so grateful that you're asking
this question because i think there's a
different way to have this conversation
than we've been having
um so
let me ask you
i got two questions one's gonna fully
answer your question the other one is
kind of a diversion here first question
is
there's something about your other two
roommates that you know they won't like
this or you wouldn't even be asking me
this question so what is that what's the
what's your concern with bringing it up
okay so
with one of the two
i'm like 99 sure she'll be fine with it
because like
she's just a level-headed person in
general i
she's even disclosed that she has a like
a stun gun that she keeps on her in her
room just for like safety reasons okay
the other one
she
she actually has um
i know it used to be called asperger's i
i know they don't really use that term
anymore right now but basically high
functioning autism okay
and we've had some issues in the past
with just her getting like overly
emotionally stimulated about certain
things like coming on in the house and
we just had some issues with that so we
aren't really sure how she would
react to even the thought of there being
a gun in the same house where she she is
okay so i want to um i don't think if
somebody chooses for them and their
household that they don't want to have a
gun in there that doesn't mean they're
not level-headed i think i think that's
fine right um i think it's a super
personal choice
um i think hysteria on either side of
the conversation um is where you get
into the level-headed conversation but
if someone chooses like
i'm just not for me i don't i don't want
that in my home i don't want the risk
the risk statistically is infinitely
more likely that you're going to hurt
yourself with your own weapon than
you're going to actually like pew pew a
bad guy that's just reality
and
um
there's also some data out there that
suggests that when people are armed in a
community the crime goes down because
everybody knows like i'm not saying i
messed around so it's both and we need
to keep having this conversation
um
so let me back out one step further why
do you
want one
do you want to go i've got some buddies
that um
they don't play golf they shoot trap
they go to the range they shoot skeet
they have these fancy shotguns and
that's just what they do that's just
their thing or they are distant shooters
they're scope shooters and they
like will sit there all day and they
dial in these things and they got these
cards for elevation and wind and they do
all this stuff
um
and they like to they like to
shoot there's something about the power
of it all and the the the concentration
and the focus all the stuff it just
becomes like a thing right like a hobby
they like to reload their own bullets on
it and then there's other friends of
mine who are former military or police
officers or people that just are have
guns they're around guns they know how
to use them and they are more bent
towards personal defense and if
something goes down i want to make sure
we're good and then i've got my other
friends
that watch way way way too much john
wick
way too much and they watch way too much
news and they're like if it goes down
i want to get on my horse and get a
sword and have my
red dot ready to
and they're insane they're my friends
but they're bonkers right so why do you
think that you want to have it is it
something fun is it exciting or is it a
self-defense thing or is it a fantasy
thing what is it
mainly i just i'm interested in like the
sport of it like the the first example
you gave just like going to the range
relaxing you know
you're shooting that focus on
concentration i've always been
interested in that not so much like
self-defense or just like crazy john
wick fantasy
okay so what i would recommend here
and and this may be a controversial
statement whatever i don't care
i think every single human being should
have some sort of training on how to
handle a weapon
even if it's to simply unload one
really quickly and it takes one and a
half i mean it takes less than a half
second to unload a gun to how they work
i think that's important how to handle
one if you ever had to pull the trigger
it's very very different if you've never
done it than you than it looks like on
tv
um and i so i i actually think that's
wise i think that's good
i think there's some steps between
going to buy a really expensive fancy
gun and all guns are expensive these
days
versus hey we're going to start going to
the range and you can rent a range gun
when you're there and they'll teach you
how to work it or you can take classes
where they'll let you use weapons when
you're there i think there's some steps
in between
the bigger question is
let's take guns off and these are like
when i get questions about um you know
transgender issues or abortion issues or
gonna i wanna take the issue off the
table for a second and just come back to
you have a value or a belief or a desire
or a need one of those four things
and you are
feeling uncomfortable living in your own
home
so the conversation is less about guns
right now and it's more about
as you described it i've got a roommate
who gets overly emotional about certain
things and i'm increasingly
uncomfortable because i can't even bring
up this i can't even have it approach a
conversation and when i find myself in
my home and i can't even have a
conversation about it then what i have
i've got secrets and secrets turn to
resentment and you hear me say that all
the time resentment turns to ash and
then the whole thing becomes a mess and
then it's not about guns at all gun
become the proxy war for i don't like
you i don't want to live with you
because i can't quote unquote be myself
i can't tell the truth in my own house
am i onto something there
yeah what's there's another there's
probably something else besides guns
that you don't want to talk to her about
what is it just pick one there's
probably several
i mean it's
living with someone who
has like that high functioning autism
it's taught me a lot about how to
put
the needs of others above my own i'm
really grateful for that because it's
taught me how to be a lot more humble
person yeah like there are certain
arrangements in the house we've had
there are certain arrangements in the
house we have to make like she
like can we have to park our cars in a
certain place in the drive through
because she has a certain preference for
where her car gets parked and her the
kitchen has to be arranged a certain way
and
i have no problem with that it's just
it's gotten a bit
much at certain times that
i've had to
go through that with her so what i would
i don't want a couple of things
you can honor her as your friend
and as a
um a woman with autism
and you can say i'm gonna choose to not
live here all that can be true at the
same time
okay
and
the
i what i don't want you to do is i don't
want to blow your house up over the gun
issue because i don't think guns are the
issue
it's not if you guys want to go shooting
i think that's fantastic i think
everybody should go take a class i i
fully believe that
um
and
i'm also a safety zealot when it comes
to guns in my own house i'm a lunatic
about the safety of it right so i think
it's all both hand
i think the real challenge here is
you've got a roommate that um you all
are starting to
get tense with and i don't want the
quote unquote gun issue to be the thing
that breaks you up i'd rather
here's my needs now my needs are when i
get home from work that i thought of oh
god i parked the car in the wrong
direction in the wrong space
i i
want to choose to not live like that and
so guys
in four or five months i'm gonna start
slowly looking for it's a new place for
me and for or for me and roommate x and
that'll be great for us it's gonna be
great for y'all we're still friends all
that i'm gonna start i'm gonna start
leaning that way this is a conversation
half and rents are
crazy expensive so you may have to find
other roommates that's fine or you can
sit down to your with your autistic um
roommate and say hey
these are really important things to you
these are really important things to me
and we have to come to some sort of
consensus because we're living together
and what i'll tell you is i've
i've worked with
innumerable high-functioning autistic
folks that hear that and get that and
i've seen some extraordinary steps
people have taken to
say okay i don't understand what you're
feeling
i can't process what you're feeling but
i trust that you're telling me the truth
and so i'm gonna act differently i'm
gonna go see my cars parked in the wrong
spot and i'm gonna feel it all over my
body and then i'm going to choose to
you see what i'm saying so
it's it's putting your needs above other
people's important and also speaking
your needs out um and letting being
heard explicitly is important too
see what i'm saying
yeah
so what are you gonna do
i might talk this over with
the other roommate who's interested and
we can see about whether or not
we need to arrange a meeting with the
other two and just
see what their thoughts are i have been
in some rooms with
folks um with autism that when
they felt ganged up on
the alarms got real real loud is there a
way you could go have coffee with with
your roommate
yeah
and say how are you feeling one on one
yeah that would that would be better
is that similar to your situation that
when everybody kind of starts saying
yeah and yeah that all of a sudden man
then
your uh your your autistic roommate gets
real defensive
oh yeah definitely yeah i think a more
humane approach might be just one on one
tell me how what you're thinking about
tell me how you've seen our relationship
over the last um and the beauty of of
not all but but some highly functioning
autistic folks is
um they're incredibly logical and
analytical it's wonderful
because we can really like you have your
needs and i have mine and they are
starting to butt up against each other
are there places where we can compromise
together i think that's a incredible
next step
and if you think of it this way you'll
be giving your roommate a gift to
you'll be giving yourself a huge gift
which is finally letting your needs be
spoken
before there's a fight because when you
have a fight they're gonna explode and
it's gonna be like you stupid liberal
and you dumb conservative now we're not
even fighting about that
the sadness is i i have to hide in my
own house and you don't want to do that
anymore and that's totally respectable
and yes go to the range go take a class
i think that'd be important i think
they'll be a lot of fun and make sure
you get a good coach and make sure y'all
really safe and
don't watch too much john wick it's just
if you have a sword and a horse for sure
you need to take out some guys on
motorcycles other than that let's just
back off the john wick we'll be right
back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right uh we are back hey james
hold on i'm getting my my cellular
device out here um so last night
i told every i told y'all in the intro
um
we went to see this these new kids that
were just
incredible it was a uh hardcore it was
it was fantastic turn style was the name
of the band
and
the show sold out like in eight seconds
like a year ago and then there's a
couple tickets this always happens that
floated up and last night it was late it
was late it was like 8 30 or 8 i texted
james was like dude we got one more come
and
james responded with
sounds epic but i can't and i said and
this is all i'm reading this i said come
on and he says
there's a all caps really good rerun of
gilmore girls on tonight
and that's all he wrote
i was hoping the sarcasm came through it
did not i here was awesome
i didn't know
and i thought that's a good friend
actually i had it on my calendar for
months that show and then i like deleted
it this week because i knew i wouldn't
be able to go so i was pretty sad
and i was hiding my sadness with sarcasm
as you sometimes do i do that on a
regular basis and can also tell you
you made a terrible choice
there's a few moments you're like all
right i'm going to hop into uber and
just be across town
it was that good
that was that good
and there were fenders everywhere not
that band the openers
there were fenders everywhere there's
enough your little fender your heart so
good all right let's go to savannah in
dallas what's up savannah
hi how are you um we're rocking and
rolling how's it going good good thank
you how's dallas is it a thousand
degrees already
yes summers are humid and hot you know
yes yeah well welcome to it so how we
doing how can i help
good um i just have a question
i wanted to know um how and when do i
tell my 14 year old little sister that
um about 13 years ago her dad sexually
assaulted me
oh
jeez man
do you feel comfortable sharing the
story
um yeah
about what happened
yes um i was i was about eight years old
um
we were sitting on the couch my entire
family my stepdad me my little sister
she was a newborn at this time
and my mom and we were all sleeping
except for him
and i woke up that's good that's good
that's good that's good that's good yeah
i woke up
and um yeah that's it
i'm so sorry
thank you
man
like the like the
i'm sorry that makes my i have to take a
breath i'm i'm taking a breath you're
the strong one here i'm taking a breath
um
that
it has a i have a uh
instant response that i have to exhale
through sometimes on those
um thank you for sharing that um so
where's that dude now
um living his life
not too far away from me
he and my sister they still have a
supervised relationship
um he's from what i can tell a good dad
to her
um by journey and everything that she
wants you know
it's not a good dad
but such it is
um
did your parents
how did your
how did it when you
did you tell walk me through posts what
happens afterwards
i didn't tell anyone for about a year
and after it happened
and when i did tell my mom
she didn't believe me you know she asked
me the typical questions like what were
you wearing i was in like night pants so
she told me that he wouldn't have done
that if i was wearing pants and
he wouldn't have done that with my mom
sitting on the couch sleeping right next
to us and she asked him and he said he
would never do anything
and so um
it wasn't
until many years later
i couldn't stand being in the same house
as him anymore and i kind of forced my
mom's hand
and she got us out
so you have the initial trauma which is
wrong it's evil
scorched earth
and then you turn to the one remaining
adult in your life and say help
and she says what were you wearing
[Music]
so that's trauma on top of a trauma and
then you got to
go home
every day
to a tiger that had already
damn near killed you once and you had to
go home to that every day
right yeah that was the hardest part
listen hon all of this was the hardest
part
i don't want to take away your story
from you all of this was the hardest
part
your mama should have believed you
should have got you out of there
and
probably i mean this is unfair to say
my dream would for you would have been
that you would have had a relationship
with her that you would have felt safe
coming that next day that's not the 14
year old there's no fault there on the
14 year old that's an ecosystem issue
you know what i'm saying
yeah and that tells me there was already
challenges in that home
um when you say you forced her hand what
does that look like because she wouldn't
have just left she would had to have
known those other issues going on
um i called her one day and i just told
her
i couldn't take it anymore and if she
didn't
do something for me i would call the
police personally
and so she came home from work and
that's when we packed our stuff and
laughed and that means she had to have
known he's abusive and other stuff was
going on
if she really didn't believe you she
wouldn't have left
yeah i mean i i'm not sure if she did or
if she didn't want me taking matters
like into my own hands
she always said that she believes that i
believe it happened oh my gosh dude
that's the most dismissive
re-traumatizing thing
wow
does she still defend that dude huh
yes she talks to him nearly every day
i don't say this lightly and if you've
listened to this show for a long time
you know i don't say this lightly you
got to get away from your mom
and i know that feels like the only
lifeline you got left but i need you to
hear me say it's killing you
um me and my mom we have a pretty good
relationship i know that listen listen
that it didn't happen but it did
and as the great vander kulk says your
body's keeping the score every time
you're around her
every conversation every time you
pretend something's not happening every
time she
like like
diverts from
where um
where she was or who she's on phone with
when you called
i'm so sorry
so when it comes to
i bet you got a uh
you better not tell anyone have you got
that
yes um i was to never tell anybody and
especially not my sister
man
and so hey so you've heard me like
here's what i know
your mother knows
something's off something doesn't right
here
and the you better never tell anybody
is almost always a cornerstone of
i know and i can't do life outside of
this context
and it wouldn't surprise me if your
mom's got a story too like uh i got some
challenges too
um
wow gosh what a mess
so
there
i i here's the deal i will not hold
secrets for people i won't
if
somebody has if i'm i'll hold
confidentiality
if um a friend of mine calls and says
hey my marriage is falling apart i need
some help
i will never tell that stuff i'll go to
the grave with those conversations
um
if someone said hey i got a secret i'm
not holding that for you it's not my job
or especially if someone says hey this
evil was done to you you better not tell
anybody nope it's not how i work
is that i work i can do that because i
know the secret kills me
saves it saves the perpetrator and it
kills me
the secrets wreak havoc on you
physiologically heart attacks cancer
stroke
it kills you okay so i'm not into the
business of keeping mom's precious
little secrets
and we'll get to sister so why now
what about right now makes you want to
go tell her
um well i just had my first baby i have
a seven month old daughter and now that
i have her
things are much more real um
now that i'm a mom myself i just
couldn't imagine being my own mom
right
and so this stuff stops with you right
exactly you're going to believe your
daughter right
yes
good for you
that you staring down a forest fire of
trauma good for you
thank you um
man and okay so hey you said it
this whole thing feels a lot more real
that's your body saying hey we remember
this story
little girls get hurt
and then their worlds explode
and then their mom puts a lid on the
explosion and makes them drink that
exploded air and blames you for it your
body remembers this story and so every
time you hold that baby little girl or
especially every time mom holds that
little baby girl
or that little baby girl is in the
presence of somebody else to sit on a
couch your body will sound the alarms
loud right and they feel like anxiety
and they feel like your stomach drops
out from underneath you and you want to
withdraw or you want to just go claw
somebody's eyes out for for seemingly no
reason that's your body saying hey hey
we've done this before we've done this
before and this time we were bigger and
we got muscles this time
right
right
tell me why you want to tell your 14
year old sister
um well i wasn't sure if i was going to
ever tell her
um
and my partner is the one who has been
really pushing me to work through this
and
find what's right and how to do the
right thing
especially for my sister
my only problem is she has very severe
anxiety
she's been medicated for it for many
years now and she's only 14.
so i'm just scared that this will
like send her off the deep end i don't
know yeah
so the two
the two
things i'm holding in tension right now
um and i'm just gonna process this out
loud so anybody listening to this this
is how i process this stuff in real time
because i'm getting this story in real
time i knew a little bit about what this
call was about um not this level
so
if you want to tell her just to tell her
don't
or if you think you can
tell her to finally get back at
don't
it won't you won't get the cathartic
moment that you think you're gonna get
okay and i know that's hard to hear
there
the the cathartic moment is the police
and let's be super honest with you it's
13 years ago
and that's gonna be a hard
case unless he's got child pornography
on his computer or a
a line of young girls comes forward and
says yeah me too me too me too
be tough right
especially when your own mom
didn't jump the gun back in the day
something tells me that she knows
something but again it's another
conversation
um
here's the other side of that tension
there's a 14 year old girl in the home
of a known sexual predator
and that's the part i'm not okay with
right well i mean it's always supervised
which leads me to believe that my mom
does know something yes
yes
so
have you gone to talk to somebody
no okay
you have to
yeah i think so i'm telling you because
i love you and
i think you're doing heroic things right
now
and i need you to hear me
that on the other end of this there is
healing that can happen and your life is
gonna look different
okay
but going along as you're going along
is a recipe for burning out and when you
get tired and you get exhausted of from
holding your
mom's fake
nonsense together and trying to protect
yourself from a woman who should have
believed you and she didn't
and also knowing that your little sister
goes to visit with a sexual predator
every couple of days even though it's
supervised
and and and and
you got this little baby with this
little baby girl
the greatest gift you can give this
little baby girl is a healed mom
yeah absolutely okay
so
you need to tell the story
and if you run and
tell it to a 14 year old now that's not
it's a it's not going to help you and b
yes i think it's going to be tough on
her so generally speaking if i'm going
to go have a conversation like that with
a 14 year old girl i'm going to bring a
professional in
i'm going to call the school counselor
and i'm going to have one or two or
three
same gendered people in their life that
are adults not kids
that can be a resource for them when
their world falls apart which it will
and when it does that is not the
person's that's not your fault
the person's fault it is is the sexual
perpetrator that hurts kids
it's the mother who didn't believe her
daughter
that's the villain in the story not you
for telling the truth
not you for saying i'm not keeping these
secrets
okay
every bit of the story will come back to
that you blew things up
you did that's what i'm scared of hey
listen it's a hundred percent coming and
that's what i'm telling you you need to
get away from your mom
you think you've made peace so you hear
here's the deal we talk about fight or
flight you've heard that before
yes okay
and there's fight flight and freeze
there's one more that we don't talk
about very often you know what it's
called fawn fawn
it's when you nuzzle up next to the
person and sometimes this is um you can
sexually nuzzle up to somebody i can
placate them
or which is a common trauma response
somebody abuses you and so what do you
get closer because it's safer when i'm
in here closer or
you nuzzle up relationally
and you make peace you concede your own
body your own safety so that the
illusion of connection can remain
and your body's keeping the score
and what i want for you
is
i want you to go home and go to sleep
i want you to hand your daughter off to
somebody that you trust and feel full of
joy that that person gets to enjoy the
beauty of your daughter not terror
i want you to be able to go on a date
with your husband and leave your
daughter with somebody and be able to
breathe and
with when you're out with your
when you're out i want you to be able to
breathe
right
yeah i always wonder um if one day my
daughter sees her as a trusted adult and
she tells her something that needs to be
reported or needs to be told to me
will she has she learned her lesson
who
my mom
like will can she be a trusted adult to
my daughter
you've got to let that fantasy go sister
she she showed you what she's what she's
made of
and i'm sorry for that because you
deserved better than that
i can get choked up on your behalf you
deserve better i got a little girl too
i got a six-year-old
you deserve better than that
yeah i know i'm sorry
the great thing you can do now is make
sure your daughter doesn't have that
you can make sure your daughter knows
she is anchored in
right
yeah absolutely and that starts with you
getting the healing that you need
probably your partner's gonna need to
join you on some of this too because
there's gonna be some there's going to
be some uh
relational dynamics that will shift and
will be hard
and
you got to stop trying to hold this
thing together because it's imaginary
and it's painful and it's duct taped and
the string is really starting to to fray
around the edges right
yes it is yeah
and i'm the only one holding it together
that's right and it's not your job
it's your mom's job
it's that piece of crap guy who abused
his job
not the little girl
and the way this will be told the story
that will be told
will roll all the way back to that six
or seven year old little girl
that this was your fault
and savannah hear me say this this is
not your fault
thank you that's
very nice to hear
no no it's not very nice it's true
okay very nice to hear is your lawn
looks nice i like what you did with the
mulch in the garden
that's that's not it's it's i'm telling
you
this one's not on you
the the healing is
it's your steps to take
here's the thing today today
open up your phone book and call a
counselor call better help if you need
to and you can we've got links there
that we can hook you up
call somebody today okay i think this
one needs to be in person if
if i i need to call somebody you can go
meet with in person pay what you got to
pay move some budget money around make
this thing happen
because you're worth it and start to
tell the story okay
and
work with your counselor on telling the
14 year old it makes me feel a little
bit better that all the visits are
supervised
um
and if she's got that level of
protection right now that she's not just
being fed a predator to a predator right
now that makes me feel a little bit
better okay right um
not a whole lot but a little bit work
through that with your counselor okay
and you're looking at about a year
probably okay
it's not quick okay
yes you're looking about a year okay
you're gonna have to learn how to do
life differently because you have been
ready to fight or run
for your whole life you don't even know
what peace feels like sister
this it's a common theme in
pretty much every uncomfortable scenario
in my life is i go i revert back to
feeling
that same feeling of um kind of just run
and hide yes
because the
one person that was supposed to have
your back didn't
and then you went to the other
for sure one person that's gonna have
your back and she didn't
and that little six-year-old girl knew
at that moment you are on your own
you can't sleep deeply you can't get
super connected relationally you are on
your own you're attending to the fire
and
making clothes and making sure that we
don't get attacked
and nobody can handle that no physical
body body can handle that
and so when i say i'm sorry you've been
carrying this so much i'm sorry you've
been carrying it so much
this is professional help level stuff
and it's going to be a process you have
to re-learn how to live and you have to
change the oil while the car's still
driving right because you got a little
one right
and you're worth every single step of
the way
thank you so so much for being brave
call us back on the way i'm walking with
you through this whole thing call me
anytime we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important that you are worth being well
and therapy is a super important way you
can show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john daloni show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back
let's go to shantae in philadelphia
what's up shantae how are you doing
good how are you dr liloni good were you
born and raised in the playgrounds where
you spent most of your days oh my gosh
that's okay yes i was
that's very cool all right so what's up
how can i help
so i feel a little guilty about making
this call um
last night um i was i was gonna call you
about like how like horrible my marriage
has been but like last night my husband
like
tried to make amends of me he hugged me
kissed me told me a lot of the times he
was overreacting was good at childhood
trauma and that we're going to be all
right we just got to keep working at it
but um i'm still going to go ahead with
my question i'm just a little guilty and
apprehensive now
um so my issue is how do you make a
marriage work
like when it's been in turmoil for
months and it's just exhausting and
draining and it seemed like you're both
are like always on different paths
even though like
it's to reach the same common goal it
just seems like you're always in
different worlds
number one thank you for being brave and
you're welcome to feel guilty it's your
right to feel guilty i hope you won't
okay
one night of
basic human
emotion one one evening of basic
fidelity if you would like emotional
fidelity being honest with you
um doesn't make up for months if not
years of
um
instability okay and so i don't want you
to feel guilty
um
can i tell you something honest
yeah last night based on your question
just now last night feels more like a
move than an honest reflective things
got to change around here am i wrong i'm
happy i would love to be wrong
that feels like a narcissist you know i
hate if you listen to the show i hate
saying the word narcissist
because i have no business diagnosing
anybody so i don't mean then diagnostic
terms but
that's a classic narcissist move
which is
beat up beat up beat up blame you
gaslights you for like well you're just
overreacting why are you so mad you
should be lucky to have me and then
there's the i'm so sorry baby
i had some stuff happen to me it's not
my fault it happened to me and i'm gonna
fix it and then it goes right back
tell me i'm wrong please i'd love to be
wrong
i was thinking did he get a hold of my
email or something no i hadn't seen your
email
no like my husband i'm thinking did you
see how i was coming on the show and
just decided to throw in the red flag
but i'm like no he didn't he has like
different passwords so
yeah it did seem odd like the time and
it was like i've been waiting for months
for this and it just right before like
last night literally before i was
supposed to wake up and take this far so
i don't okay i'm gonna flip things
around on you okay
okay to answer your question
you don't
you cannot make a relationship work when
everybody's on the same on different
pages
when you have secrets from each other
you got to hide stuff from one another i
don't tell him that stuff because that
sets him off i got these passwords
because i can't trust him with this i
don't want him seeing that
it doesn't work
period
um
you have to to make this thing work be
on the same page
um
when you said i've been waiting for this
for months
if nothing else on this call i want you
to hear me say never ever wait again
you're worth more than that shantae
and what i mean by that is
just waiting for somebody to quote
unquote figure it out or come around
is that's how you end up and also in a
decades gone by and you have two kids
and another one on the way and you're
like who am i and what happened and i
wanted to be a doctor and now i'm
working part-time you know what i mean
your life just slips through your
fingers while you're waiting on somebody
else to meet your needs that that you
didn't speak out loud
and so hear me say as firmly as i can
you are worth your needs being spoken
out loud
and you may have never even seen that
you don't have a picture of what that
even looks like in your mind so i'll
give you one
that looks like
he goes off on you he's angry
and you say i'm gonna stop us right now
you or anybody will not talk to me in a
disrespectful tone
you will treat me with respect i'm gonna
step out
and i'm gonna go for a walk around the
block and i'll be back in a minute and
we're gonna do this again later or
i'm gonna take a couple of days
and i'm gonna go stay with my mom and
then i'm gonna circle back and we'll
have this conversation when the smoke
clears here but this isn't gonna how
we're gonna interact i'm worth more than
this that's what i'm talking about okay
yeah um and i know that's hard there's
economic concerns there's all kinds of
things that make that really challenging
um
tell me what happened last night
um
so last night we were just um laying
there and well he kept dinner first and
then he was being playful with with me
which i really didn't know how to
respond because sometimes like
when i'm playful back it might turn into
something so i was just letting him do
his thing and he's going to like this
hold on it might turn into something
like y'all might end up sleeping
together or it might turn into something
like it ends up he gets mad because it's
not going like because he's losing
control because you're playing along too
oh now we love event that we slept
together
but um
no it's more like i might say something
but he didn't find what i said to be
appropriate funny or now i'm not in the
mood to play anymore and you play too
much and
yeah
so like that okay
so i just let him you know do his thing
play um just chuckled a little bit
didn't say much and then um
we went to bed and then he hugged me
kissed me um told me that sometimes his
reaction is because you know what he's
been through
because he's traumatized from his
childhood and that we're going to be all
right and we're going to be okay um but
just last week before then he um
he walked past me after we had like a
disagreement on something that it was
small to me but i guess it was big to
him and he threw his ring at me and said
we're separated and i'm like that's not
how separation works i mean we're still
living in the same house where he said
oh well you know well you've been
married before to know that he was being
sarcastic because this is like our first
marriage with each other like you can't
tell me how separation works
and um
so he took his ring off um
and
told me that he's been looking for rooms
and whatnot um
in case if i basically if i do one more
thing to upset him
before june happens he's going to
go explore an option and rent a room
somewhere just to get some peace and
clarity because i don't bring him peace
and um
and then so
it's been like real rocky but then last
night it just seemed to be real calm and
him throwing a like finally throwing
like a loop or a ring towards me when
it just seemed like we were going on a
completely like opposite end so
so can i ask you um and i'm not asking
this in a disparaging
way are you hard to live with
um
maybe no no shantae tell me the truth
are you hard to live with
i don't think so but being with him i
started to question am i
and um i don't think it's that i think
he because here's why i say that we both
work like i work the nine to five he
does as well
and sometimes like um he might not say
it but he'll expect me to do the
traditional full-on like house
duties while i'm still working so
sometimes i'll say hey what can you help
out or if i clean up can you just be
like
more aware not to just leave your stuff
around because when i'm coming when i
leave out for work and the house is
clean i would like to come into a clean
house first every single day having to
like keep cleaning the house because
he's kind of like
messy yeah so to speak he's not nasty
he's kind of messy and his thing is be
like you're the one you pick it up like
basically i'm begging him he doesn't
want me to control him
so man okay i think maybe in that case i
am but it's not like you can go like you
can he could be on his phone for hours i
won't bother him because i have my own
stuff going on so i didn't think i was
hard to live with
and i'm not like a smothering type i
don't smother it's like you can do your
own thing it's fine like it's not like
your own thing like that but like i'm
not constantly on you
like shantae you all are newlyweds in
your first year of marriage
yeah
this weekend is our one year anniversary
oh man this should be
like i know oh my gosh you're hiding in
your own home and so is he
and
i i i can't say anything negative about
him because he's not on the phone with
me okay
and so i'm gonna assume that after a
year the whole house is just hard
right
yeah and i'm gonna i'm gonna choose to
say you know what
that guy had a moment of clarity
and he realizes he loves you
you're special
and he wants to do what he has to do to
make this thing work and he may have
never told anybody about childhood stuff
that happened and that was the first
time he spoke at all so i'm going to go
down that road okay
so here's the next steps and i don't
know another option around these next
steps
you have two actually you have two paths
forward
path number one is this
and this ends at some point
okay
yeah
path number two is this
you tell him
our one year anniversary is coming up
and before we go do something romantic
for our anniversary i want to have a
follow-up conversation on what we talked
about last night
and this isn't a spring it on him this
isn't uh he's watching tv and you go
turn the tv off this is
on friday
i want to go out and i want us to have a
grown-up conversation we need to have
and here's what that all that
conversation is is this
you said we're gonna be okay
you said you've got some childhood
struggles that you're working through
you said you're sorry that and if you
have things to apologize for shantae
what you probably do say em say i'm out
loud and
say
being okay moving forward looks like
this for me what does it look like for
you
and you're gonna have to i would if i'm
you i'm writing this stuff down
it looks like i need help around the
house
we're both working i know there's some
traditional gender roles i need some
help here
i can't work a full-time job and then
come home and work a full-time job i
need some help
number two
don't ever throw your ring at me again
i need us to always know that no matter
how sideways things get our marriage is
okay
that we're committed together
and if you tell them you're going to
look for rooms before you start looking
for rooms at least honor me enough to
say hey here's what i'm struggling with
in the house
and not wait till there's it's the door
shut you know what i mean and so
whatever those needs are for you
um
i need you to be more playful and sexual
with me i miss you i need right i want
you to be really explicit about your
needs
and this is a low reactivity
not gonna fight
i'm not gonna argue i need you to listen
to all the things i'm gonna say and then
you listen and then i'll listen to all
things you're gonna say we're not gonna
lob grenades at each other
but we've got to make a plan for moving
forward and then here's the hard thing
us being okay means you're gonna have to
go talk to a counselor about your
childhood trauma that's what you gotta
do
and i know that's not cool and it may
not because buddies may be that that's
what you're going to have to go do if
you're serious about healing from that
stuff
and
we'll i'll even go with you if you would
like but we're going to do this together
you see what i'm saying here's what i'm
trying to give you back shantae i'm
trying to give you your power back and i
want your husband to have his power back
and i want you all to have power
together and i want you to look at your
relationship apart from each other and
say let's make this thing really good
how can i help meet your needs and
here's my needs how can you help how can
i help you meet my needs see what i'm
saying but that yeah but that's the
thing i suggested counseling like
together and individually
one like a few weeks ago and then he
said that um he'll get there to the
counselor and say all the right things
and when he leaves that he's not
changing he's going to do his own thing
because he's stubborn and no one's
telling him how to live his life
but i also forgot to mention in the
email because i was just so overwhelmed
with my own emotions
that he he was being a therapist before
we got married but because he had um he
was diagnosed with ptsd and anxiety
um and he's he was taking
like medicine for it but then he stopped
and like he he says off and on that like
he's gonna go back and he's gonna you
know but it's never no follow-through
then when i finally mentioned counseling
again he was like i'm not you know those
people they're just working a job you
know when they leave they do what they
want when i leave i'm gonna do what i
want but you can waste your money if you
want to okay so
so here's the thing you can't control
him he's a grown man
the only person you can control and this
is hard is you
and right now you need somebody in your
corner on a regular basis i don't think
good therapy is a waste of money in fact
i think it is a lifeline for many many
of us millions and millions of us
and i do hear that a lot and i get that
that someone's just doing a job they're
just pushing paper and pushing a broom
yeah i don't know therapists like that
the therapists i know deeply care about
people and
they want them to have peace in their
life and laughter and joy in their life
and good sex lives with their spouse
they want these things for them and so
this idea that they're just like getting
a job and clocking out it's not true
they're i'm sure they're therapists out
there i just don't know them
most they're even the ones i disagree
with how they're doing it they really
want what's best for their clients so
it's not about i'm gonna tell you what
to do
it's hey if you're coming to me and say
it's like going to the gym right the
trainer's like what are your goals well
i want to get huge all right well here's
the workout plan for getting huge i
ain't doing that
okay
like it doesn't affect my workout if
that's your choice you make cool you
know what i mean so it's less about i'm
telling you what to do as a counselor
and it's more
hey you just explain this out here's the
path towards
changing your family tree
here's the path towards sleep and my
heart breaks for him
because it sounds like he had a rough go
of it as a kid is that true
yeah he did he opened up to some things
prior to talking marriage and during
marriage
um
yeah it's a lot yeah
and so here's the deal
um
i'm gonna send you a copy he may not
read it you can read it you can leave it
laying around i'm gonna send you a copy
of my new book on your past change your
future okay
the whole premise of that book is we
have to look in the mirror and say this
stuff happened to us
it happened okay full stop i got abused
someone treated me wrong because the
color of my skin somebody hurt me
somebody beat me up so this these things
happen to me
and there's a period at the end of those
sentences some of them i'm still in an
abusive relationship i'm still being
treated differently because um a woman
in a workplace right whatever the thing
is
i have to look in the mirror and own
those stories
and then i have to ask myself that one
terrifying scary brave question
what am i going to do now
am i going to continue this cycle
or
am i going to take one or two years of
my life and it's going to be hard and
brutal and challenging and i'm going to
change
everything
right yeah and he has to do that work
you can't do it for him
i'll tell you this he's lucky to have
you okay
why'd you marry
why'd you marry him
um
i always tell him that he's brilliant
like he's karen he's um like his heart
like once he gets an idea and you just
see him go like he gives it his all
um he's protective and he's caring like
over like who he loves um
overall he does have a good heart it's
just
um
i just haven't been saying that lately
but
and he's funny he's nice he's kind he
has
goals and dreams for himself and not
selfishly like oh i just want this like
he cares about the children he he wants
he wants more and he's ambitious and
just him like you'll never meet like him
like wherever you are like you'll never
meet him
in him like he's one of a kind
sounds like you love that guy
yeah
and it sounds like you're also exhausted
yeah
do you do you hate the fact that the guy
you love is hurting so bad
yes of course
okay have you told him that
it's kind of hard i don't know like i
know
i don't know how to like gauge him
sometimes okay
um where i've seen effective in the past
is people sometimes write letters
when somebody sits down and says hey
what you told me last night boom
if you're a trauma survivor
your walls go up immediately right then
i'm not hearing a word you're saying i'm
just trying to survive this conversation
and if i means at the end i have to just
brush you off if i have to pull out my
phone and act like i'm ignoring you if i
have to
be overly emotional and yell something i
will survive this conversation
what a letter does sometimes is it
allows that wall to come up and then it
goes back down because there's not the
person in that room and i can read it
again and then i can read it again and
then i can read it again
and the second time i read that letter
the second and a half time the third
time
now i'm starting to hear it
not always sometimes people read it once
they throw it away in the trash they say
don't ever write that that's fine that
happens
but sometimes they read it again and
again and they start to go oh my gosh
that woman loves me
so here's my rule of thumb if you are
not safe
if you are worried about your
psychological or physical safety you've
got to get out you promise me
of course okay
deeper than that
you are worthy of your needs and the
greatest gift you can give him is
telling him here's what my needs are and
it's going to come with a risk because
he might look at you and say i'm not
meeting those needs i'm out
and if he does that would be because he
chose to go not because your needs were
wrong
okay
that's the only path forward for both of
you
and if you the second thing you got to
ask him is
and what are your needs how can i help
meet your needs
and how do we do these things together
okay and that's not me that means like
okay then i got another eight hour shift
after i get home where i gotta re-roof
the house and mow the yard like that's
not what that means
but that means we're gonna have this
conversation together i need you to pick
up your clothes that's not too much of
an ask i need you to help with the
dishes that's not too much of an ask i
need you to give me an hour and a half
at night just to let me
have some breathing room cool i'm in for
that i need to just be able to go to the
gym cool i need to be able to cool well
we can make those things happen
i'd love to meet this guy sounds like
he's great
sounds like he's hurting a lot and he's
trying to figure things out
i don't know if he's great i don't i
don't i haven't met him but it sounds
like he's hurting he sounds like he
loves you he's trying to figure it out
clarity clarity clarity and you need to
make the call and go see a counselor
okay it's the only person you can put
into counseling is yourself
please make that call because you're
worth it we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloni.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's show
in honor of the concert last night
it's from the band turn style the song
is holiday
man those boys from jersey put it down
song goes like this
now it's a holiday make a little room i
want to free up from the vine i want to
celebrate close enough to feel and now
it's time to disappear i want to
celebrate
so i can never feel the cold i can never
feel the cold now it's a holiday too
bright to live too bright to die i want
to celebrate beauty is built not from
the outside and i imagine it so i can
never feel the cold i can sail with no
direction i can sail with no direction
like it's a holiday
we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode i'm just
trying to figure out what is fears
versus what are the red flags when it
comes up in our relationship a red flag
for me is something that violates one of
my core values why did you get separated
um
mainly because of his drinking
and i know that you know what i'm about
to say okay
you're trying to keep a fantasy alive
and you have to let it go and you
laughed but only part way and if you're
gonna be gone after three years you
gotta go your kids are
bearing the brunt of this